네 오늘 나스닥이 큰 폭으로 하락하고 있습니다. 1.7%나 하락을 하고 있고요.
다우지수, S&P500, 러셀2000 전부 다 하락을 하고 있고요.
특히 러셀2000이 가장 큰 폭으로 하락을 하고 있어요.
중소형주 위주로 되어 있는 지수인데
금리 인상이나 인플레이션이 왔을 때
더욱더 금융구조가 취약한 회사들이 중소형주이기 때문에
대형주야 돈 빌리는 게 그렇게 어렵진 않거든요.
대형주야 재무구조가 탄탄하니까.
근데 중소형주 같은 경우는 재무구조가 탄탄하지 않기 때문에
이렇게 돈 빌리기가 어려워지고
그러다 보니까 시장에서 더 안 좋게 보는 경향이 있다.
이렇게 볼 수가 있겠고요.
시장의 우려, 좀 간단하게 정리를 해보면
현재 이란 전쟁이 아직 완전히 끝난 상태가 아니잖아요.
원유와 에너지의 공급이, 전세계적인 공급이 감소하고 있고
자, 공급이 감소하는데 수요가 그대로라면 에너지의 가격이 상승하겠죠.
에너지의 가격이 상승하면 세상 모든 게 다 원유로 굴러가지 않습니까?
그러다 보니까
물가가 상승을 합니다.
인플레이션이 발생한다고도 얘기를 하죠.
자, 이렇게 인플레이션이 발생을 하게 되면
여러 가지 방향으로 시장이 흘러갈 수가 있는데
아주 단순하게는 일단은 금리 인상을 할 수밖에 없어요.
그러니까 중앙은행 같은 경우는
물가가 지속적이고 아주 모멘텀을 갖고 상승하게 되면
매우 골치가 아프기 때문에
불을 끄는 심정으로 금리 또한 같이 올리게 됩니다.
자, 그래서 금리를 올리게 된다?
그러면 당연히 주식은 좋지요.
좋지 않겠죠.
왜냐하면 주가라는 게 미래 현금 흐름을 오늘날로 가지고 온 건데
그 미래 현금 흐름을 할인할 때
금리라는 것이 활용이 되거든요.
그런데 금리가 올라가면
미래 현금 흐름이 할인이 될 때
그 할인이 되는 폭이 훨씬 더 커지다 보니까
우리가 수학적으로 봤을 때
주식의 할인 요소가 너무 커지게 되는 겁니다.
그러니까 주가가 안 좋고
2022년도에 있었던 바로 그 스토리죠.
또 나아가서 현재 시장의 주도주라고 할 수 있는
반도체 주식에 대한 우려
뭐 약간 비슷하면서도 다른데요.
방금 제가 보여드렸던 주식에 대한 우려 플러스
조금 스토리가 다른 거는
금리 인상이 되면은
혹은 경기가 이런 상황에 영향을 받게 된다고 하면
빅테크가 캐펙스라고 하죠.
빅테크가 데이터 센터를 짓기 위해 쓰는 돈이 줄어들 수가 있습니다.
왜냐하면 경기가 너무 안 좋으니까
혹은 비용에 대한 큰 부담을 느끼고
그렇게 되면서 빅테크가 캐펙스라는 걸 줄이게 되면
반도체 기업들의 실적이 감소하겠죠.
그러면 반도체 주식이 하락을 하겠죠.
그러면서 반도체 주식에 대한 우려가 또 이렇게
이런 스토리가 만들어지고 있다.
스물스물 올라오고 있다.
물론 이제 얼마 전까지는 호르무즈 해업은 해업이고
지금 AI 기업들 1분기 미국 기업들이
실적이 역대급으로 좋았거든요.
그래서 알바 노? 알바 없어.
어차피 실적 잘 나와.
호르무즈 해업이랑 AI랑 무슨 상관이야?
라고 생각했던 시장이
오늘 약간 CPI 지표를 보면요.
물가지수 지표를 보면서
깨달음을 시장이 좀 얻었다.
이렇게 볼 수도 있을 것 같습니다.
오늘 물가지수 간단히 말씀드리면
소비자 물가지수 전월 대비 0.6% 상승을 했고
예상치를 부합한다라고 볼 수는 있는데
그럼에도 불구하고 전 연대비로 보면
물가가 예상치는 3.7%였는데
실제 나온 지표는 3.8%
그러니까 1년 사이에 물가가 3.8% 올랐다라는 얘기입니다.
이거 자체도 상당히 암울한데
왜냐하면
3.8이라는 이 숫자 자체가 암울하잖아요.
근데 더 안 좋았던 건 뭐냐면
바로 근원 소비자 물가지수가 높게 나오는 거였습니다.
근원 소비자 물가지수가 전월 대비 0.3% 상승할 거라고 예상했으나
그것보다 조금 더 상승을 했어.
0.4% 상승을 했고요.
그래서 전 연대비로 봤을 때는
2.8%가 근원 소비자 물가가 올랐다.
이렇게 보시면 됩니다.
참고로 일반 물가지수에 비해서 근원 물가지수는 이런 차이가 있어요.
음식과 에너지와
음식과 에너지를 제외한 물가입니다.
찐 물가라고 보셔도 될 것 같아요.
왜냐하면 음식과 에너지를 물가지수에 포함하게 되면
변동성이 너무 커지는데
음식과 에너지가 외부 요인이다.
이렇게 보거든요.
그러니까 금리를 인상하건 안 하건
사실 에너지 가격이 마음대로 오를 수 있잖아요.
금리 인상한다고 해서 호르무즈 해업에서
평화가 생기는 건 아니니까
그러니까 음식이나 에너지 같은 경우는
기본적으로 통제할 수가 없는 거기 때문에
통제할 수 없는 거를 제외하고
정말 찐 물가만 보자라는 관점에서
근원 CPI라는 걸 측정을 하는데
문제는 뭐냐?
근원 CPI 물가도 시장의 예상치보다
더 높게 나왔다라는 거죠.
다시 말해서 이렇게 볼 수가 있습니다.
에너지만 물가 상승이 있는 게 아니라
이 에너지의 물가 상승이
다른 분야의 물가 상승으로
번지고 있다.
이렇게 볼 수가 있는 거죠.
그러니까 어떻게 보면 문제가 더 안 좋아지고 있다.
이렇게 해석할 수가 있는 겁니다.
자 이렇게 봤을 때도
오버롤 물가지수
그러니까 일반 CPI의 경우에는
회색으로 되어 있는데
많이 내려왔잖아요.
많이 내려와서
뭐랄까
근처를 크게 이렇게
튀면서 움직이지 않았는데
갑자기 물가가 팍 튄 겁니다.
그래서 시장의 걱정을
자아낼 만한 그런 요소다.
이렇게 볼 수가 있겠고요.
얼마 전까지만 해도
연준의 가장 큰 이슈는
금리 인하를 해야 되나?
이게 이제 연준의 가장 큰 이슈였는데
연준의 완전히 포커스가 바뀌었죠.
이제 연준의 가장 큰 이슈는
금리 인상해야 되는 거 아니냐라고
금리 인상을 해야 되는 거 아니냐라는 거죠.
그래서 연준의 어떤 스토리가 완전히 바뀐 거고
너무 당연한 얘기지만
결국에 이란 전쟁 어떻게 해결되느냐에 따라 달린 것 같습니다.
자 그래서 오늘 하락한 주식들을 좀 보면
히트맵이라고 하죠.
히트맵을 보시면 아시겠지만
주로 이제 반도체 관련된 것들
빨갛다 이렇게 볼 수가 있겠고요.
최근에 많이 올랐던 것들이 얻어 맞았다
이렇게 보시면 돼요.
그래서 최근에 미장을 이끌던 주도주들
보면 마이크가 많이 올랐다.
마이크론이 8%나 하락을 하고 있고
인텔도 최근에 거의 한 달 사이에
거의 100% 가까이 올랐거든요.
인텔도 9% 하락을 하고 있고
센 디스크도 원래는 짱 센 디스크였는데
이제는 좀 약한 디스크로 바뀌었죠.
그래서 9% 하락을 하고 있습니다.
자 그리고 한국 증시도 매우 어려울 것 같아요.
EWY ETF죠.
한국 ETF인데 한국 ETF가
8% 현재 하락을 하고 있습니다.
그래서 한국 증시 매우 안 좋을 것 같고
이거 국내 야간 선물을 봐도
코스피가 3.68% 하락하는 걸로 나오고 있기 때문에
이거 국내 야간 선물을 봐도 코스피가 3.68% 하락하는 걸로 나오고 있기 때문에
아 이거 빡세다 이런 생각이 듭니다.
그리고 채권금리도 보면은
10년물 채권금리가 4.4
30년물 채권금리는 5.0이 넘었는데
특히 10년물 금리를 조금 더 보면요.
거의 연초 대비해서
최고 금리선까지 다시 왔어요.
자 금리가 높다라는 거
채권금리가 높다라는 건 뭐냐면
채권가격이 매우 낮다라는 겁니다.
채권가격이 낮다라는 건
채권을 선호하지 않는다는 건데
왜 채권을 선호하지 않을까요?
인플레이션이 무서운 거죠.
채권은 정해진 금액을 받기로 한 거기 때문에
물가가 올랐을 때 가장 피해를 보는 자산이 채권
그러다 보니까 인플레이션에 대한 두려움이 있는
그런 사람들 입장에서는 채권을 싫어할 수밖에 없겠죠.
그래서 그런 것들이 이렇게 시장의 모습에서 나왔다라고 볼 수가 있겠고요.
자 그리고 간만에 또 유가도
한번 보겠습니다.
WTI가 100불이 넘었고 브렌트유는
지금 107불까지도 올라갔는데요.
또 왜 이렇게 양대 유가가
다 100불이 넘었느냐
봤을 때는 트럼프가
또 이란에 대해서 한마디 했기 때문인데요.
트럼프는 분쟁 종식을 위한
미국의 제안에 대해서
이란의 대응안이 나왔는데
그걸 또 거부를 했습니다.
이란이 제안을 했는데 이란의 제안이 쓰레기고
휴전이 생명유지장치에
놓여있다라고 경고를 했어요.
놓여있다라는 건 뭡니까?
휴전 안 할 수도 있다.
뭐 이런 식의 경고를 하다 보니까
또 유가가 올랐다.
이렇게 보면 될 것 같고요.
자 그러면 2022년처럼
다시 한번 인플레이션이 폭등하고
2022년도에 주식시장 정말 힘들었거든요.
그런 힘든 악몽같은 장이 또 반복되느냐라고
물어보신다면 저는 솔직히
그럴 가능성이 있다라고 생각을 합니다.
자 왜 그렇게 생각을 하냐면
너무나도 당연한 2022년에
러시아 우크라이나 전쟁 위기점에
이번에도 호르무즈 이슈가
공급망을 흔들 수가 있다라는 거죠.
그리고 아직까지도 전쟁이 끝나지 않았고
또 이 호르무즈 해업이 막히면서
오는 이 나비효과에 대해서
우리가 완전히 알고 있는 상황이
아니다 보니까
이게 어떻게 흘러갈지
이거의 키나 그리고 에너지 가격을
급등시킬 텐데
여기서 오는 이 파장이 분명히 있을 거다라는 겁니다.
그러면 또 이것이
제가 맨 처음에 이야기했던 대로
금리 인상을 불러일으키고
금리 인상을 불러일으키면
당연히 주가에는 안 좋고
뭐 그런 스토리로 흘러가는 거고요.
그래서 결국에 우리가 봐야 되는 건
이것이 바로 꾸준한 물가 상승으로 이어지는지
결국에는 다음 달 CPI가 더 중요해지는 것 같습니다.
그리고 그것에 대한 연준의 반응 역시 중요하겠죠.
연준이 만약에 그냥 이거 무시하고
결국에 AI가 디플레이션 갖고 올 거니까
야 알빠노하고 금리 인상 절대 안 해
이렇게 버티면 그래도 괜찮을 수 있는데
연준이 이걸 좀 보면서
살짝 놀라면서
금리 인상으로 가면은 또 스토리가 바뀌는 겁니다.
이거 어떻게 될지
또 다음 FOMC에서 새로운 연준 의장과 함께
우리가 지켜봐야 될 부분인 것 같고요.
현재 패드워치라고 하죠.
투자자들이 베팅을 하는 거라고 보시면 되는데
금리가 어떻게 될 거냐라는 베팅에서는
2027년 4월 정도에
금리를 한번 깔짝 인상할 수는 있겠다
정도로 현재는 시장이 생각을 하고 있습니다.
다만 제가 제 영상을 오랫동안 보신 분들은 아시겠지만
저는 한쪽 의견만 강하게 주장하는 스타일은 아니에요.
그래서 반대의 주장도 한번 좀 우리가 생각을 해볼 필요가 있어요.
2022년과 오늘날의 장이 좀 다르게 흘러갈 수도 있다라는 논리가 있는데
대표적으로 한 세 가지 정도가 있는 것 같아요.
첫 번째는 바로 기저금리가 다르다라는 겁니다.
2022년은 제로금리에서 급격히 금리를 올리던 시기다 보니까
이게 제로에서 출발할 때는 이 금리 상승의 폭이
체감이 얼마나 크겠어요.
이미 제로금리 시대였기 때문에 돈이 정말 무분별하게 풀려서
별별 곳으로 돈이 다 풀리던 시기에서
갑작스러운 금리 인상을 짧고 굵게 그리고 매우 크게 했기 때문에 충격인데
이번에는 만약에 금리 인상을 하더라도
그 강도가 이미 시작이 거의 4%대에서 시작하지 않습니까?
그러다 보니까 금리를 올려도 상대적으로 그게 티가 덜 날 수 있다라는 얘기죠.
또 인플레이션의 절대치에서도 큰 차이를 보이는데
2022년 같은 경우에 미국 CPI가 9.1%까지 올라갔는데
현재는 겨우 3.8%긴 한 거죠.
그래서 뭔가 통제불능의 느낌까지는 아니다라는 그런 느낌이 있고요.
그리고 당시 기업의 이익들, 특히 주식시장을 무너뜨렸던 것들은
돈 못 벌면서 거품스러운 기업들이 많이 망가졌는데
2026년에 현재 시장을 이끄는 테마는 특히 빅테크들,
생각보다 비용 구조도 착실하고 돈도 잘 벌고 있는 회사다라는 거고
또 AI가 어떤 혁신이라는 게
2022년에만 해도 혁신의 에너지가 약했던 시절인데
2026년은 이미 채찍피티가 나온 그 이유죠.
그래서 이 혁신의 에너지가 있다라는 게
2022년과의 다른 부분이 아닐까라는 생각을 하지만
어쨌든 간에 이 양쪽의 이야기를 다 들어보고
우리가 더 면밀히 관찰을 해야겠다라는 결론을 내리면서
저는...
오늘 영상 여기서 마무리하고요.
저는 또 돌아오겠습니다.
구독과 좋아요, 알림 설정 부탁드리겠습니다.
감사합니다.